à ces gentils raymonde nous avoir
emmenés à la campagne ce qu'on est bien
puisque je vais aller m'asseoir et nous
préparer quelque chose à manger
ah oui nous allons faire des recettes du
style recettes de camping dans le soleil
l'a broyé 4 au soleil non c'est là sous
l'arbre la soul a rebondi blanc et on va
peut-être sous la tente en iran va
surtout là pour préparer la cuisine
pièce maîtresse ou l'atteinte après pour
la déguster et oui je dis ça sur un
petit temps triste parce que en levant
la tête moi ici je vois quoi des
sunlights des micros les oignons des
poivrons une cocotte de l'huile enfin il
ya quand même pas mal de gens sont
encore bien non non la vérité c'est que
nous sommes pas encore encore et encore
la vérité c'est que pour notre prochaine
émission
eh bien nous serons au salon du camping
d'ailleurs ce jour-là comprend la remise
des prix 1 ce sera la remise des prix
aux assauts gagnants du concours la
cuisine pour les armes a fait ça au camp
d'essai du sentiment tablier je voulais
que vous nous fassiez une petite chose
parce que vous nous proposez un poulet
andalouses ont pris à temps et à temps
d'intervenir je vous fasse un cas à
écouter pour justifier pour tout de même
en fait en fait tu dois vous dire alors
offert en aveux on en veut d'ailleurs
qui joue beaucoup au caire
c'est le fait que ce poulet nahd
andalouse en vérité que le nom car
l'autre jour lorsque j'ai présenté la le
titre de l'émission animée comment
s'appelle-t-il sur poulet alors l'idée
qu'il y avait des poivrons qui servait
de base en quelque sorte à la
préparation
alors j'ai dit andalouse mais il est
probable qu'ils ont et y avoir des
poulets andalouse dans les livres de
cuisine qui ne sont pas du tout celui là
c'est pas andalou rebondit assez
masculin
ça ne fait pas l'ombre d'un loup gerald
andaloussi ça parce que je voulais qu'on
voit bien ce qu'il fallait une demi
seconde là encore que gilbert dessus des
seuils de fond c'est pour tout à l'heure
car voilà des poivrons des soignants je
pense que vous les voilà
et puis une boîte de lait concentré de
vie voitures et skate ou sans nous
allons sucrer de la campagne alors on
n'a pas grand chose n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens
et puis de l'huile d'olive sel des
milieux la verte
alors voilà tous les ingrédients et
disent maintenant je vais me mettre à
cuisiner parce qu'il faut tout bien nous
ayons le temps
non c'est pas ça et fauqué de temps de
cuire alors le premier la première
démonstration à faire c'est comment
compte-t-on en poulets alors voyez vous
la cuisse ici comme ceci jusqu'à la
jointure depuis on rabat on passe le
couteau à l'intérieur la jointure et on
tire alors ceci on a extrait l appui
sport alors on enlève voyez-vous le plan
oui c'est en coupe d'un couteau coups de
couteau siècle dans la jointure pour la
défaire notre plutôt coups de couteau
c'est difficile à dire cinq coups de
couteau le contraire toutefois le véloce
de façon à ce que ce soit plus haute
et voici la crise alors on répète
l'opération comme ceux ci et là il est
différent verse de façon à libérer la
jointure on extrait voilà merci alors
que nice un coup de couteau dans la
jointure afin de séparer un petit coup
de cutter que tous là pour casser l'os
que l'on coupe et que l'on enlève comme
ceci et puis maintenant nous arrivons à
l'aise d'abord on enlève les l'euro les
deux ailerons exactement cette recette
peut se faire en cuisine n'est pas
fabien surtout d'honneur aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas que nous sommes à sarry
magie de la cuisine
alors voyez vous on prends le couteau
dans la jointure de l'ale et en coupe en
rond comme ceci de façon à détacher
entièrement alors on refait salle où on
prend le morceau d'aileron qui restait
dans la jointure très exactement
elle est toujours à sa place d'ailleurs
ça arrive
oh ça arrive bien sûr alors ici on
enlève le blanc un petit poucet qu edith
walla et si on perd un camping on
emporte un grand couteau comme ça
ah oui il faut absolument il faut peu
d'outils gentil mais il faut de très
bons outils peu parce que on a peu de
place et le poids est commun aviation
l'ennemi essentiel de quemper mais par
contre je ne bouge pas mais par contre
les outils doivent être excellent il
vaut mieux un très bon grand couteau
d'ailleurs les couteaux de temps peur
ces couteaux avec manches liège vous
savez qui vous lie lorsque l'on s'en
sert pour se baigner ou en fait pour
faire la pêche sous marine
et bien c'est un excellent couteau c'est
souvent de très très très bon couteau et
qui sont très faciles a ensuite employé
alors je voudrais la farine 4
bon alors première chose les morceaux de
poulet je vais les assaisonner du sel
quand ça c'est on peut prendre une
planche pas n'importe quoi sur wii
soyons on se fabrique des planches très
facilement et messieurs sont très
contents si son parti est partie des
joies du camping
enfin n'importe quoi on peut peut faire
la fusée finir par faire trouver que de
faire la cuisine est une joie du camping
à metz et tous les joueurs je vois tous
les jours d'ailleurs accueilli ici bien
sûr mais en particulier aux copains
alors que d'habitude on campe ils ont dû
manger du jambon manger des jeux n'est
pas d'ailleurs ce n'est pas exclu mais
pas plus que de temps en temps on ne
voyait pas cuisiner quand vous seront
alors fermées alors la voyez où je m'en
vais pour paris une gamme ça aussi c'est
une chose que dont on peut se passer un
cantique de paris né je le fais parce
que c'est tout de même mieux mais on
peut s'en passer on peut très bien
mettre le poulet à cuire dans l'huile
sans pour autant le farine est tellement
tellement c'est moins joli l'île de
l'hydre risque d'attaché penser ce que
je veux que ce soit en daluz oui c'est
ça c'est le côté en la loose
recette c'est l'huile d'olive c'est le
premier chercheur de la corrida les
clarines
on jetait la saône à riom j'y connais
pas grand chose au tas comme si vous
aimez assez sages avaient alors croyez
au ici c'est un très bon alors nous
allons laisser colorer les deux côtés cc
pour un côté nous allons donner de la
couleur à l'autre côté et puis nous
allons pousser sur un peu moins vie
pendant que nous allons préparer le
restant de la recette c'est à dire les
oignons et les poivrons
alors voyez où ça va être vite fait
[Musique]
alors je vous ai promis je tiendrai ma
promesse vers les 2 oignons dont nous
avons parlé alors chez jauniaux nous
allons l'aider mais c'est très très
finement toujours pareil il y a la jeune
femme joue des castagnettes alors si
vous vouliez catherine jouer des
castagnettes pendant que lui et ses
minces et les oignons il me semble que
ce régime qui tire au but et ce tout à
fait penser que je vais vous faire un
entier tous moi je crois vous faites un
peu les boules c'est ça oui à côté
voilà les audio maintenant nous
voudrions 4 poivron jaune là on parlait
de 4,4 alors les 4 poivrons c'est à
l'envers
oui alors sur la couleur ils peuvent
peut-être de la couleur que l'on veut
voir parfois rouge alors oui oui là où
il n'y a pas du tout de graines bio
alors sont les mêmes ce sont les mêmes
et devient rouge en dix ans nous sommes
déjà promises et voilà eh bien nous
voilà voilà nous prouverons vrai je
regarde un peu ce qui se passe à la
cocotte
on va pouvoir revenir ici un peu plus
près de vous et je m'excuse monsieur je
vis au quotidien est vraiment pas ce qui
fait tâche quand une marche blanche
[Musique]
non merci alors voyons je vais retirer
le poulet d'ailleurs c'est une rose de
redouter une rose de rebaisser vient
dans les samples mission non il n'est
pas puni les dorer les saisies il a pris
couleurs alors je reçus au jeu le vc la
casse voilà non on ne sent rien les
alors je met immédiatement l'oignon
émincé très fin dont préfet insiste
beaucoup sur la pinède
parce que le temps de cuisson est
relativement faible et pour qu'ils
cuisent roues d'un peu d'huile ça fait
alors je vais ajouter de l'huile une
goûte bien entendu jean grey une
gouttelette semaine nous pousse
l'introduire voilà bien savoir de votre
bien
c'est très bien et puis tout de suite
voyez-vous qu'ajoute plaît les coupés au
site reste je m'en vais immédiatement
mettre sur ses poivrons et ses oignons
des feuilles de thym et où j'ai dû
tendresse est ici alors je vais essayer
comme ceux ci ne faut pas exagérer
compass pour pas que je ne sente que le
tiens parce que c'est le défaut dépit
des herbes sèches comme ceux ci c'est
qu'on risque d'en être trop et se
sentent vraiment que je sais c'est pas
ce pas là le but recherché du tout alors
j'ai salle et le poivre et le poulain
je vais également salée et poivrée
maintenant le
pognon et nous avons eu peur du moulin
du poivre du moulin
merci catherine voilà aujourd'hui jean
moulin à poivre qui fonctionne à
merveille
voilà et bien c'est suffisant maintenant
comme avis sur la joue puis je dis à ces
risques incluent sûr ça m'a inspiré
enfin vous y mettez d'ailleurs c'est
aussi bon avec les chocolats l'été alors
voilà eh bien
catherine je m'en vais maintenant
laissez cuire ceci pendant un certain
temps pas très longtemps mais quelques
minutes
bon alors il était pendant que vous
allez laisser cuire ça nous allons
peut-être pouvoir aller prendre l'air ça
serait une très bonne idée de prendre
l'air voilà voyez ça marche doucement
assez doucement et je crois que c'est
bien comme ça voilà c'est bien moi je
suis déjà venu prendre mais vous n'allez
pas me laisser errer moral et me
rejoindre
je suis là au milieu de cette voyez
maintenant je suis à côté vous pouvez
refaire la proportion regarder je touche
ici la cocotte c'est un autocuiseur je
crois oui c'était un autocuiseur
parfaitement gars très petites maquettes
de l'endroit où nous nous trouvons dans
quinze jours pas tout à fait quinze
jours dans une dizaine de jours puisque
c'est le 10 avril que nous y serons pour
une émission du 17 et voilà cette petite
chose est ravissant vous pouvez nous
dire un petit peu ce que c'est que ça ça
va cuire pendant ce temps ça va oui ça
le fourneau le follow montrer le viol
est celle par là parce que oui c'est ça
qu'on le voit bien regarder ça c'est le
fourneau main à gazon peut transporter
sa ba oui c'est une bouteille ça c'est
une épine containers qui sert à porter
l'eau apportée d'ailleurs toute autre
espèce de liquide même de poissons lamy
en pente alors ça devienne et ça à
regarder ça c'est un barbecue vaio
regardez cette toute petite fourchette 7
aux petites cuillères à la cueillère là
dedans c'est dans le
euh comment dirais-je la glacière mais
là ça on met la glace et les objets que
l'on veut mettre de temps et là on aura
tout ça et qu'est ce que vous allez nous
faire des recettes alors cette fois
c'est vraiment campeggia aujourd'hui
c'est m un tout petit peu d'inspiration
camping c'est son héros c'est très
simple il vous faudra je crois justement
notre cuisine
oui je me servirai d'autocuiseurs parce
que je pense qu'effectivement
l'autocuiseur surtout lorsqu'il est
double parce qu'il a il peut servir à
toute espèce de préparation et le
l'instrument je vais pas fouiller
l'instrument idéal du camp fini
maintenant
l'instrument idéal de cabine parce que
justement il sert à peu près à tous
réalisés à tout faire alors je pense que
c'est effectivement ça vite le gendarme
dire ce que c'est que c'est un nom aulas
nous par contre il me semble que je
voudrais que ce soit un peuplier moi ça
m'arrangerait ça sent très très très bon
mais alors je vais j'y reviens pour ne
rien vous cacher notre campagne n'est
pas très très loin de notre cuisine
alors je continue à regarder ça parce
que sont vraiment des rires des ces
petits ciel sont absolument adorable et
je vais rejoindre maintenant vraiment
l'hiver en vous laissant encore respirer
l'air frais pendant quelques secondes et
bien catherine voilà je crois que nous
n'avons nous n'avons pas à nous
inquiéter beaucoup ça cuit admirablement
bien
et pendant que ça va finir de cuire que
nous avons encore besoin d'un petit
moment à parler de lui vous savez que je
revienne est arrivé on a dit savoir
pourquoi vous êtes revenu alors là je
vais vous faire monsieur alors il vous
fait une démonstration avec l'appareil
aujourd'hui à nom catherine non je n'ai
pas à battre l'américain au contraire et
vous si nous exportons maintenant
quelques petites voitures du style le
plus petit que nous ayons et qui a
beaucoup de succès mais que nous
exportons aussi des objets ménagers
parmi lesquels celui ci est celui qui a
le plus de succès à l'amérique
d'ailleurs sa masse je me souviens tout
d'un coup d'une histoire américain
jallet qui sait c'est d'ailleurs la
manivelle qui ne fait pas ses seuls
enfants américains qui rendent chez lui
et qui dit à sa mère maman je vais me
trouver un tourne-disque formidable il
n'y a plus besoin d'électricité on le
remonte à la main c'est tout à fait je
vous rendrai le sien ceci oui des
légumes alors ceci le grand besoin alors
soit il y en a beaucoup mais je me rends
bien il faut alors voici des carottes
des carottes bananes ya pas la quantité
des 40 qu'il avait ses maîtres ce que
veulent enlever et tout ça c'est andalou
tenue ça je vous en fais cadeau fait
cadeau tout ça c'est un lourd enfin non
ceci c'est camping
il est il est de règle que les campeurs
soit un peu végétariens et alors il leur
faut toujours des légumes au début de
chaque repas il est conventionnelle de
manger des légumes crus ou alors
sélectionné alors les légumes crus en
les faits comme ceux ci voient les hauts
fourneaux vous savez vous venez me gêne
je deviens moderne
quatorze états unis pour nous rapporter
des instruments france est désormais
neige il y avait tout ça
[Musique]
aux etats unis en dehors de ça au bon
rap et ça au nord de soi quoi quoi je
crois que vous avez parlé on vous a fait
parler politique et non oui surtout moi
ristournes tout le monde mais nous
disposons d'une émission de 28 minutes
mais là-bas combien de temps sa durée
alors nous avons commencé l'émission 11
heures du soir et nous pourrions encore
à 4 heures du matin ce avec et je ne
croyais pas qu'il y avait une seule
personne pour nous écouter
et chaque fois qu'on nous couper les
doigts car on nous coupe tout je ne sais
combien de minutes pour passer une rente
et de lycées publicité alors j'arrive
avant de couper je disais mais vous
pensez pas qu'on pourrait en temps la
maison selon ses goûts mais ça va très
bien il est dit alors je fais penser que
probablement il avait raison vous avez
continué à écouter autres villes celles
de vos ancêtres
alors non mais on m'a posé des quantités
de questions qui intéressait beaucoup
tout le monde entre autres qu'est ce que
c'était que les truffes par exemple ce
qui les intéresse beaucoup autre terre
ah oui ça les intéresse énormément à la
question des trucs parce qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas justement et s'étalent les
truffes et les ortolans ce sont des
choses qui les étonne beaucoup d'abord
que nous mangions d automne en ce qui
ressemble à un être tout bêtement des
moellons doigts et 10
le moineau tout de même ce sens mange
pas alors évidemment quand puis-je me
permettre c'est peut-être quelque chose
que vous attendriez aussi avocat
français si vous voulez un jour leur
expliquer oui aussi comme les truffes et
remarqué ya des quantités junkie qui
ignore absolument ce que sont les
truffes et quand nous pensons que nous
mêmes nous le savons que depuis très peu
de temps
il ya moins de 100 enfin parce que là il
ya moins de 50 ans même que nous nous
sommes sur l'origine réfugiés des livres
sur les crues ne m'avantage jusqu'à
quatre noms utilise fortement que le
seul moyen pour obtenir des truffes
ces deux plantes et de mettre en terre
des cornes de béliers par exemple ah non
je pense que l'économie a relevé la
superstition
l'équipe ans est aussi que les rues rené
uniquement lorsqu'il y avait plus de
l'orage les années sans orage et l arrêt
centre ou alors vous pouvez vous offrir
ce petit appareil reste à savoir si
c'est merveilleux je crois qu'il
faudrait gens normaux mais je vais bien
sûr pas capables de
je vais quand même offrir ce luxe de
faire de 2,6 via la mer alors oui l'ont
lâché j'ai longtemps eu de la chance
émincer ici un petit peu de show rouge
l'occasion et qu'est-ce que j'ai dites
moi qu'est ce que ça à voir c'est un
peuple et non pas du tout mais ça se
servir avant ou après si c'est pour
donner aux coulées le temps d'accueillir
sept îles ont eu tord à la campagne fait
une faute et doit même faire mieux ce
poulet alors voyons oui je vais
maintenant forcé l'alluré où il vous
reste vie minutes en plein deuxième nous
avons même je crois demandé les clarines
pour le troisième on va pouvoir se
découvrir si j'avais si je portais la
torte j'avais vu ce geste merveilleux
matador matador qui lança montèrent
derrière désinvolte
bon ben moi j'aime pas les causes de
temps et ça ne fait rien on est là et
consorts les fifties
voilà ça fait mais bien vos poids gros
commence à fondre oui j'ai entendu
maintenant je suis aussi
alors voyons où jouer mais si les choses
sont tous contents départ elle n'était
pas du tout rouge doit dans le vert
genevois recommande bien parce que ces
zones tout de même pour ces légumes
desservir sa horde heures faisant neuf
morts dont les crudités on peut on peut
dire ce que je n'ai pas cogité souvient
s'en servir comme principale vous devez
pas accepter ravissante actrice
attendait celle la réduction exacte de
notre décor pour le salon du camping
si le ciel veut être avec nous tout dire
s'il n'est pas avec nous il sera sur
nous la voilà nicheuses des carottes des
navets voit là et bien là je voudrais
pas que ça allait trop vite
non ça découvrez vous voulez découvrir
quelque chose tout à fait là alors ici
les choses sont bien des mythes plus que
jamais pressé le même nom que vous avez
besoin
si je lis bien rester à ça je ne sais
pas déjà lu nacion être la caméra nous
peut distinguer les différences de deux
timbres mais vous mais je vais mettre ça
va pour qu'on voit bien c'est ça que je
vois bien la différence de couleur alors
maintenant
sortir de la cellule rouge la lasser les
carottes donc c'est rouge orange et puis
là c'est le navet s'il avait ça c'est
blanc ah oui c'est dommage dommage et
intérêts alors vous allez votre poulet
et bien catherine je voudrais qu'on le
voit voilà alors je vais me voyez vous
les deux morceaux de carcasses et le
morceau de blanc au milieu pour rester
dans le classicisme les deux cuisses de
poulets dans le bon comme ceci voilà les
ailes dans le milieu de chaque côté puis
immédiatement que ouvrir cette boîte de
lait c'est du lait concentré non sucré
secret c'est très important
on pourrait se servir de l'est tout
vêtement ou bien aussi
on pourrait servir de crem alors la
crème vraiment c'est plus du tout qui
sait pas du tout le style de cette
recette je trouve alors il faut de la
cadac 1 me dit fleurette la crème très
très c'est très légère
allez-vous alors là on arrive à
l'épaisseur exact en ajoutant au fur et
à mesure de la crème la crème de lait
concentré pendant secret' lait concentré
non sucré faut arriver exactement
l'épaisseur voulu dire que la demie
boîte qui est un demi litre est
largement suffisante mais quelque fois
ça peut être trop alors il s'agit juste
d'arriver à la limite voulu voyez pas
tout tout va pouvoir y aller de rien je
n'ai regardé tous verts que voulez vous
regardez crise
oui j'ai bien géré mes bras j'appelle ça
ne me vois pas ce que la boîte est en
ligne
voyez alors c'est un de mes dès 2010
de l'est je sais pas si c'est un oubli
aussi ses 530 savary je crois je crois
qu en blanc aussi le le mot tinée 2000
teen love quoique ça c'est pour le
biscuit
enfin moi non je ne veux pas dire des
sottises parce que je sais qu'il ya des
appellations selon lui selon les rennais
n'ont pas les régions selon les produits
que l'on met en bois très bien voilà
alors voilà le pourrait il est cuit je
tiens il ya le bien le préciser qu'il
est cuit il est cuit dans les délais
c'est à dire il faut moins de vingt
minutes pour cuire et voilà la sauce qui
est prête et que vous allez voir qui va
parfaitement se présenter il n'y a pas
de légumes 6,6 alors là évidemment
lurette un légume qui sembleraient
s'imposer de lui-même en fait de légumes
et bien c'est assez curieux objet du riz
je mettrai volontiers du riz mois avec
une scie nouveau set de ce style là tout
à fait pratiquement il est terminé
alors je voudrais faire faits attendez
j'ai le temps de faire en assaisonnement
beaux mes petits légumes alors je m'en
vais le faire rappeler recettes quand
même oui je vais l'avoir l'avoir solide
c'est tout de même le centre je vais la
rentrée alors du sel du poivre
il y a de la motor dans une petite dans
une petite cocotte et on a de la
bouteille qui poserait pas vu tout ça
alors de la motor non je vais en prendre
une demi cuillère comme ceux ci le
vinaigre qui va pas au bout
merci 4 et je vous répondre
autour de vinaigre un tout petit peu et
puis en demi citron alors ça c'est au
goût alors vous avez les deux huiles du
citron le jus d'un citron
naturellement si j'avais un peu citron
si nous n'avons pas ne pas gaspiller du
tout nu dans cette période
rue c'est vraiment un modèle alors
beaucoup de fines herbes le camp grande
quantité de finnair la voici le décor
hyper si c'est du père si c'est du
persil avec un peu de surf et est un
tout petit peu des trois grands et puis
je mets deux fois plus presque trois
fois plus d'huile plus jeune amy de
vinaigre et de jus de citron le jus de
citron et les villes est évident que
ronan mes mom et moins de lui le par
rapport à la quantité du titre on que
par rapport au vinaigre
c'est bien maintenant catherine je vais
vous rappeler la recette alors il s'agit
donc pour les couper en morceaux saisie
à l'huile d'olive
lorsqu'il est colorée on le retire et on
met dans la même île depuis sont des
zones ion est mince et extrêmement fin
et aussi des poivrons et mince est
également très fin pour les colorer les
deux les poivrons et oignons dès que
c'est coloré on remet le coup les deux
dents on couvre on assaisonne légèrement
et on laisse cuire à l'étouffée environ
un quart d'heure en quart d'heure et 20
minutes
pendant ce temps là évidemment on peut
faire ce que l'on veut en l'occurrence
nous sommes allés à la campagne louis
voir l'installation
voilà aussi préparer les légumes qui
sont des hors d'oeuvre en quelque sorte
nous allons ajouter sur ses légumes là
les avis aussi il y est ouverte mi-juin
donner une touche verte assez amusante
c'est très jeune voilà
et puis nous allons présenter le poulet
sur lequel nous allons pouvoir ajouter
aussi si nous le voulons un tout petit
peu de films serbes contre soi on a sous
la main un ballon mais je crois que
c'est une bonne chose et lorsque nous
avons fini la cuisson lorsque nous
sommes sûrs que le poulet est cuit ou
leur tirons nous le peuple nous le
mettons sur en plat et dans cette même
cocotte dans laquelle nous avons fait
cuire les les oignons et les poivrons
nous ajoutons du lait concentré non
sucré jusqu'à ce que la sauce est
exactement l'épaisseur si ce que nous
désirons lui voir atteindre alors dès
que cette épaisseur est atteinte
nous versons la sauce sur le plan et
nous servons que je veux permettre de
vous dire c'est une recette qui me
paraît simple et que nous aurons
volontiers accueilli dans nos foyers
peut-être plus simple même que la
dire que vous nous aviez proposé et qui
était proposé aux messieurs la potée
dieppoise qui avait nécessité c'est une
offre c'était une recette qui m'avait
été communiquée et que je tenais
beaucoup à réaliser parce que je pense
que c'est une excellente recette de
soupe de poisson je sais que les hommes
adorent à la fête est aussi ramené de la
pêche leur poisson le faire goûter à
leurs amis alors tout ça me paraissait
être quelqu'un quelque sorte télégénique
et tous les hommes et râleur c'est
pourquoi les hommes et mettra l'air
c'est pourquoi vous allez terminer là
votre émission d'aujourd'hui et en
terminant bien sûr cet arrimage et
d'aujourd'hui nous allons retourner un
petit peu à la campagne qu'à cette fois
je crois que nous y resterons presque
une dizaine de jours pour nous y
retrouver donc au salon du camping le 10
avril pour l'émission du 17
bon appétit à tous et merci maman
[Musique]